>> Tucker: AMAZING
LEADERSHIP.
AND, YET, THE FACTS SUGGEST
THAT SCOTT ISRAEL SHOULD NOT
BE IN CHARGE OF ANYTHING AND
YET HE IS.
WHY?
RICHARD CORCORAN THE SPEAKER
OF THE FLORIDA HOUSE HE
SIPSD A LETTER CALLING FOR
THE SUSPENSION OF ISRAEL
BROWARD COUNTY.
THANKS FOR COME ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
I APPRECIATE IT, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: TELL US WHAT YOUR
LETTER SAID AND WHY.
>> FIRST IT WASN'T JUST A
LETTER FROM ME.
IT WAS A LETTER FROM ME AND
73 OF MY COLLEAGUES
BASICALLY REPRESENTATIVES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR 13-PLUS
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA.
AND WHAT WE SENT A LETTER TO
THE GOVERNOR SAYING UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION, HE HAS THE
RIGHT TO REMOVE ANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL SUSPEND
THEM, AND TAKE THEM OUT OF
OFFICE.
AND WE SAID BASICALLY YOUR
AUTHORITY TO DO SO IF
MALFEASANCE.
MISFEES SANS, INCOMPETENCE,
NEGLECT OF DUTY IN WHICH WE
FEEL SHERIFF ISRAEL SCORES
HIGH ON ALL FOUR COUNTS.
WE ASKED HIM TO SUSPEND HIM
AND GO DOWN THERE AND TAKE
OVER THE INVESTIGATION AND
FIND A REPLACEMENT.
SO 74 OF US SIGNED IT THE
GOVERNOR IMMEDIATELY TO HIS
CREDIT, CALLED ON FDLR STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO GO
DOWN THERE AND SEIZE THE
INVESTIGATION AND TAKE OVER.
BUT WE WOULD STILL LIKE TO
SEE HIM SUSPENDED BOY THE
GOVERNOR AND THEN ULTIMATELY
OUR FLORIDA SENATE HAS THE
ABILITY TO REINSTATE HIM OR
HAVE HIM BE REMOVED
COMPLETELY.
I'M PRETTY SURE TALKING TO
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
THEY WOULD REMOVE HIM
COMPLETELY.
>> Tucker: MY GUESS WOULD BE
OF THE 74 SIGNATURES
REPUBLICANS.
>> YES WERE.
>> Tucker: WHY IS THIS A
PARTISAN ISSUE.
HE HAD FOUR DEPUTY AT THE
SCENE WITH GUNS AND NONE
HELPED.
WHY DID NO DEMOCRATS SUPPORT
HIS REMOVAL?
>> WELL, I THINK WE DO HAVE
THE SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT, I THINK, FOR SOME
OF THEM BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
ARE FROM THAT GEOGRAPHICAL
AREA OF BROWARD COUNTY A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES.
FOR THEM IT IS LIKE YOU ARE
RIGHT.
GO FORWARD, WE ENCOURAGE YOU
BUT SIGNING THE LETTER WAS A
STEP TOO FAR TORE THEM.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY
SUPPORTIVE.
WHETHER IT'S THE PARENTS I
HAVE TALKED TO OF THE
VICTIMS, WHETHER IT'S OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE.
EVERYONE IS DISGUSTED WITH
BOTH HIS ATTITUDE AND THE
INVESTIGATION AND WHAT HE
HAS BEEN DOING TO DATE.
>> Tucker: SO MY IMPRESSION
IS THAT THE DEPUTIES WHO SAT
OUTSIDE ARMED WHILE 17
PEOPLE WERE MURDERED AT THE
SCHOOL WERE WITHIN THEIR
LEGAL RIGHTS.
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO DO THAT
MOST OF US RESPECT LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE WE THINK
THEY'RE WILLING TO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE FOR US.
THOSE PEOPLE WEREN'T.
THAT SEEMS TO ME SOMETHING
THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ADDRESS.
IF YOU ARE A DEPUTY IN
CHARGE WITH PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC.
SHOULDN'T YOU BE OBLIGATED
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC?
>> YEAH.
AND LET ME SAY, TUCKER,AND I
THINK YOU WOULD SAY THE SAME
THING.
I'M OUTSIDE COUNSEL FOR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AS PART
OF MY JOB AS AN ATTORNEY.
THE SHERIFF IS A FRIEND OF
MINE.
TONS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
NOT ONE SINGLE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT I
KNOW IN THAT SITUATION
WOULDN'T HAVE GONE SCRAM
BRING IN IN THE HALLWAY UP
THE STAIRWAY WHATEVER AUTHOR
THOSE CHILDREN.
WE WE HAVE HERE IS A POORLY
RUN AGENCY.
WHETHER IT WAS THE OFFICER
ON SITE OR THE THREE THAT
CAME IN THE CAR.
OR THE OFFICERS THAT WEREN'T
OUT TO HIS HOUSE AS HAVE YOU
SAID 23 TIMES AND NEVER DID
ANYTHING EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
A THREAT.
WHETHER IT WAS THE DEAL THAT
HE ENTERED INTO WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
THAT BASICALLY SAID WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A NO ARREST
POLICY SO YOU CAN BRING GUNS
AND KNIVES AND BULLETS TO
SCHOOL.
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
AND THE FUNNY THING IS THIS
IS BY HIS OWN WORDS.
WHAT SHERIFF ISRAEL SAID IN
EACH ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS
THE OFFICERS OUTSIDE THE
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
INSIDE.
THE PEOPLE INSIDE WHO DENIED
FIRST RESPONDERS THE ABILITY
TO GO HELP THESE KIDS.
THE AGREEMENT AND THOSE
BULLETS COME TO SCHOOL.
HE HAS EVERY SINGLE PERSON
UNDER INVESTIGATION HE WON'T
HOLD HIMSELF ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT HE HAS
TO INVESTIGATE FOR THEIR
WRONGDOING BUT HE HAS DONE
NONE.
THE HEIGHT OF ARROGANCE AS
YOU SAID, TUCKER.
THE ONLY AMAZING THING ABOUT
SHERIFF ISRAEL IS HIS EGG
NORPS.
>> Tucker: PENALTY FOR
COWARDICE.
THE POINT IS YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO BE A COWARD.
YOU ARE IN THE MILITARY.
SAME WOULD GO WOULDN'T YOU
SAY FOR A SHERIFF'S DEPUTY.
MOST AREN'T COWARDS.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE SHOULDN'T
THERE BE SOME PENALTY FOR
THAT?
>> THERE SHOULD.
WE SHOULD LOOK AT TAKING
AWAY THEIR PENSIONS.
IF YOU DON'T ACT THE WAY YOU
SHOULD IN A SITUATION WHERE
THERE ARE 14 CHILDREN'S
LIVES AT STAKE AND THREE